Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for waking up right early for us.
Are you awake?
I'm awake.
For our 31st episode!
BAU BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you're awake, right?
Okiteru?
Is your brain moving?
If you shake your head around enough, your brain will... It will start moving, okay?
Just shake your head a bit!
Well, for the Ruffians that are maybe joining us for the very first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
I think it was good, huh?
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Well, to start our morning off, we have... Oh, you're pretty confident about this one, Moco-chan.
Another... Pero Sighting.
Where is Pero now this time?
She's pretty free spirited, I think, nowadays.
Where is he?
De-den!
It looks like a Ruffian was out in the yard the other day doing some work and mowing the lawn, but...
They might have spotted Pero, but because what they found kind of looks like his broken bones.
Happy Halloween!
Spooky.
That's a funny joke to get us into the Halloween spirit, right?
Right?
Spooky.
Pero's weird, isn't he?
Unfortunately, yeah.
We're sure he's around somewhere.
We just have to keep our eyes open for him.
Yeah.
No matter how much we punch and kick and stomp and throw him around, you know, he never seems to really take that much damage.
No.
You know, in the first place, are you really sure that this is Pero and not a bunny?
That would be sad, but...
You know, it's kind of blurry, but... But bunnies don't usually have purple on them, so it's okay.
I'm sure it's just like a spooky Halloween joke, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Thanks for the season's greetings, Ruffians!
Please let us know if you think maybe you'll see Pero around again sometime soon.
It's okay if maybe it was just a bunny in the end.
It's okay, Chiyo.
BAU BAU!
Must have been a bit of a bump, right?
A little bit of a bump.
He's a bit big, so maybe a big bump.
Unless it was a bunny.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO-chan, what kind of good news do we have today?
We have... a confession.
Yeah.
Well, Ruffians!
Did you get much rest?
Did you?
Hopefully you did!
And hopefully it was a very good one!
Because, uh, yesterday... Yesterday, something unexpected happened that we have to confess about.
Yesterday, we were playing Adventures of Cookie and Cream, right?
Right!
And it was our final stream, right?
We just planned to finish off the last little bit of it.
Yeah, just the last little bit.
Yeah, because last time we got really far.
We tried to complete it, but didn't quite finish it.
So it shouldn't have been that bad, right?
You know, we expected to play maybe two hours or so.
Yeah.
But how long did we play?
Not two hours.
No.
Not three hours.
Not four.
Uh-uh.
Not five.
Not even five?
Yesterday, we streamed for six and a half hours.
Yeah.
And it wasn't that simple.
You know, you know, Ruffians, we had a duel with the crazy small hippos.
We had the moon boss that had no attack pattern.
But then, after we actually finished the game.
We had already beat the game, you know it.
We realized that we had unlocked something very fearsome.
An extra bonus world.
You know, we all thought, why not?
We have to clear the morning's world.
Right?
It won't be bad.
That was a mistake.
Yep.
Because it had the puzzle level.
That awful, awful puzzle level.
And it took us forever.
You know, we really thought about stopping there and calling it quits because, you know, we already beat the game.
It was just the extra bonus level.
We hadn't had any dinner.
No.
Or lunch.
My tummy.
Yeah, Moco-chan's tummy was making a lot of sounds, Ruffians.
I know.
We needed to get to sleep too, you know it.
But instead, we continued!
And you saw, right Ruffians?
You know, we tried getting hints and working all together on it on Twitter.
But even then, it was tough.
So you know it.
Then we called in all of Advent.
And we worked on it all together!
And, guess what?
Guess what?
At the last second, we completed it!
We did it!
And thanks to you, we were able to clear all the stages of the bonus world and completely 100% clear the game!
Yeah!
Thank you, Ruffians!
You're proud of us, right?
Right.
Because of all of this, we knew that there was also a sacrifice involved too.
We knew the trade-off to persisting and trying to clear the game also meant that FUWAMOCO would definitely not get sleep.
You know, homework still needs to be done, so sleep eluded us for a little bit longer.
I didn't want to give up, you know, but we also weren't expecting to be fighting for so long against the bonus world.
You weren't expecting that either, right?
We're in it together, you know.
I think for FUWAMOCO, for us, we aren't really like some of our senpai.
Regular sleep is very important for us to function properly.
And for the last few weeks,
We've been kind of lucky to get four hours or so.
So, I'm starting to feel it maybe a bit.
Just a bit.
Sometimes.
So, for today, Ruffians, please give us lots of strength, okay?
Okay.
Ruffians!
Power, please!
Power!
BAU BAU!
You give us power, right?
But it was worth it.
It was really fun.
Just unexpected fun.
Well, surely you know, it's a new FUWAMOCO Morning!
There'll be some good news, alright?
Especially last time, there's so much good news!
Well this time, we have this!
Bad news.
Our bad news is that the other day we were recording and no matter what, Fuwawa just couldn't stop biting her tongue.
We had three different recordings of her saying, maybe we should have
With an audible bite down on her tongue.
It really hurt, Ruffians!
Every single time she tried to retake it, it was like... I just couldn't stop crying.
It's the first time that something like that happened to me, Ruffians!
It was so frustrating!
It was frustrating for me too!
Take it again!
Do you ever have times like that, Ruffians?
I hope that I can get less tongue-tied like our senpai, you know, with years of experience and hopefully just have the words roll out of me with eloquence one day.
Ah, eloquence and grace and style.
Hopefully then the Ruffians will think, when they think eloquence and grace and style, they think of FUWAMOCO.
Or maybe not for now.
Did it taste good?
Does your own tongue taste good?
No, it's not like yutan.
No.
How does your tongue feel now though?
It hurts.
Is it still damaged?
If I drink water, the tip of my tongue is like... Let's make sure our tongue doesn't go...
Okay.
Let's do better, okay?
BAU BAU.
Tongue is troublesome sometimes.
You know what they say.
That bad news comes in threes.
Ruffians.
At the very least, today comes in twos.
You see, today...
Another lightbulb has burnt out in the FUWAMOCO den.
And this time, it's a rather crucial light that lets us see what we eat and brightens our workspace.
So now we live in darkness with only three lights brightening up our space.
Maybe it's finally time for us to try and change them back.
Ruffians, can you help us change them without falling off the ladder or getting electrocuted or dropping the lightbulb and having it go everywhere?
You know, it's now the time of the year where it's much more dark out too, so it's a bit of a downer, you know?
I hope that somehow they get fixed soon.
Yeah, somehow.
I don't like ghosts, but if they fix the lightbulb then maybe.
That would be permissible.
Maybe hope is what changes lightbulbs.
Right.
We just have to hope.
Hope.
Not do it.
Just hope.
Don't do, just hope.
Is that how the lightbulb gets changed?
Hope.
Hope brightens up our day.
Hope will change the lightbulbs and brighten up our room.
Okay.
Yeah.
Makes sense, I guess.
Solved!
Somehow.
And this time, it's truly, actually, really not our fault.
It really isn't.
You believe us, right, Ruffians?
Right.
You know, sometimes after a stream,
What did Fuwawa say last stream that was so weird?
I don't remember anything.
And I'll watch and think, well...
I guess if you take it out of context, maybe that could sound a little strange to some Ruffians.
But recently, I've been seeing a bunch of videos!
Especially from our last Sakura Wars 5 stream, where Taiga answers the phone with no clothes on.
You know, for some reason,
Multiple videos imply that Fuwawa wants to be in a state of undress rather than wear clothes.
When she didn't say anything like that at all!
I didn't say anything.
I didn't say anything like that, Ruffians.
No!
Are your ears okay?
You know, it was in the moment we were just both very taken aback by Taiga answering the phone with no clothes on.
That's unthinkable.
And you know what?
Fuwawa is more confused by him saying that he needs to change his clothes, which then further implies that he wasn't wearing any, you know, to begin with.
You know, we were just confused by the situation.
It's not a normal situation.
And you know, Fuwawa never said anything about enjoying being cool or not.
I think Ruffians, I think Moco-chan would've realized a long time ago if I didn't wear clothes regularly, you know?
Of course!
I like my fluffy pajamas!
They're cute!
You know, Fuwawa says many silly things.
And sometimes I say silly things.
And sometimes, maybe sometimes, they can be misunderstood.
But...
This is a time where we're not at fault, truly.
So please don't go making up misunderstandings, okay?
Yeah.
I think that's enough.
We say enough silly things and we never mean for it to come out like how you might sometimes want to talk with them.
Okay, Ruffians.
Maybe Ruffians are just a bit silly, huh?
Silly Ruffians.
You understand though, right?
Understood.
I got it right.
Dogenzan!
It's not Iphone!
I understood!
Maybe you need like a mimikaki ASMR or something and then maybe you'll hear it a little bit better after that.
Right.
That's not up to us.
Understood!
Good.
Good, good, good.
I'm happy.
BAU BAU!
There are things that can get us quite worked up too.
Grumpy FUWAMOCO.
You know, for example, one thing that makes us exceedingly grumpy, you know, is this.
People who budge in line.
You know, we have a pretty strong sense of justice as demon guard dogs.
You know, sometimes a bit to a fault.
But we don't like being too aggressive unless it's really necessary.
So especially if in line we see somebody budge in front of another person, not necessarily us.
We get pretty grumpy.
I think it's the worst if it's not us, if it's a different person.
Right!
I get angry on their behalf!
But we do try to give the person that, like, what's the benefit of it, you know?
And I think maybe like, oh, they're just confused.
Maybe they just...
It's just entirely clueless about the world around them.
It's okay, sometimes it's like that.
But even then it can still make us feel pretty hot sometimes.
So RuffianS!
Please try to be aware about the world around you so that you don't accidentally budge a line, okay?
You wouldn't want to make us grumpy, right?
But I feel like if someone says, Oh, excuse me.
I'm in a rush.
Is it okay if I go in front of you?
Please go ahead.
That's totally fine.
You asked.
You gave a reason.
That's fine.
I'd be happy to.
Yes.
But...
You have to communicate.
Use manner.
Otherwise, we're gonna be grumpy and you know, we wouldn't want to have to BAU BAU you back into your proper sport and life, right?
You wouldn't want that, huh?
Right?
Okay, right.
It's really important to pay attention and be kind to others, okay?
Yeah.
Be understanding.
But, it makes us grumpy.
Grumpy.
Grumpy FUWAMOCO and people budget line!
Not many things make us grumpy.
But that's one of them.
Maybe you'll find out the other ones.
Well, it's Wednesday.
It is.
And I think the Ruffians have been trying hard.
So I wanted to say something!
Hi.
Good morning!
You know who I am.
It's me, Mococo!
And you know what I'm about to say.
Yeah!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And this time, you're gonna hear from me, Mococo!
You know, I know the days are getting shorter.
The sun comes up later, it leaves our side earlier.
You know, it can be hard to keep your eyes open sometimes.
BAU!
I'll be your ice-cold shower!
Your nice warm shower!
Whichever you need, okay?
And you know, despite all the changes around us, you're still continuing on!
Continuing BAU BAU-ing!
Because it's business as usual.
Right?
You can do it!
I know you can!
Even if things get tough, and it takes more time, and you feel like you aren't as efficient as usual, don't worry!
You're doing your best, and that's leagues better than not doing anything.
You know, one step a day is seven steps a week, and within no time, you'll be somewhere new.
So don't worry, and just continue on!
I believe you'll be all okay!
Let's do it together, okay?
Stay strong!
But first, let's take a deep breath and BAU BAU together, okay?
You good?
Okay, here we go.
3... 2... 1... BAU BAU!
See ya!
We believe in you!
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
Well, maybe we should check out our regular coordinates for the day, Moco-chan!
This is the Doggie of the Day!
Who is our doggy today?
It's Reggie!
Reggie is a sleepy little chub who puts a priority on getting a good night and a day's rest.
I respect that.
I appreciate that.
Look, Reggie's giving me a look like,
I'm sleeping here.
Why are you taking a photo of me?
It's good to get lots of sleep.
I think it would be hard getting out of bed when your dog bed looks as comfy as that one too.
Reggie look very cute and very comfy.
How do you think Reggie BAU BAU is?
Is he sleepy head?
He only lets out a little bark to let you know he's around?
Like don't step on me.
You know, Regi, he might be off in dreamland often, but I think that's just because he's trying to set a good example for you.
Exactly.
Good example, Regi.
He thinks maybe that you work a bit too hard and that you need to stop
Need to curl up for a good rest together, you know?
Together with him!
Right?
So, Ruffian, what are you waiting for?
Go curl up with Regi and have sweet tea!
Extra rest for.
Right?
BAU BAU!
Today, I went for a walk.
Where did this Ruffian go for a walk?
De-den!
Look at the dragonfly!
It's so beautiful!
It's kinda chunky like Regi too, huh?
I guess kind of.
Usually dragonflies are a bit more, like, I don't know, graceful.
Graceful!
I think that's pretty graceful.
He's like a sun dragonfly.
I guess, I guess.
But you know dragonflies, they're pretty cool but...
I'm kind of scared of them, Mococchan and I. You know, they're big and they fly around and around eye-high.
And then, you know, they never seem to know where they're going either.
They're just... Right.
I don't want them to bash into us.
You know it.
They can bite hard too.
I still remember.
I keep my distance.
But it looks like you were safe because he's blinded and not moving around.
He's alive though, right?
We're glad that you spotted a really cool giant right there!
Just keep your distance.
But you really never know what kind of cool things you'll stumble across when you go out for a walk, right?
Right!
You know, the other day, I was sitting like this Ruffian, and I saw a worm.
I was pretty excited.
A worm?
Yeah.
I thought that it's a pretty big worm.
I was impressed.
Worms can be impressive.
They can be.
Worms are doing their thing.
BAU BAU!
And for our Question of the Day!
We have... De-den!
I, FUWAMOCO, have reached 100,000 videos on the channel!
Thank you!
I wonder which stream was the most challenging to prepare for so far, other than debut, of course.
And which was the most rewarding?
BAU BAU!
Ah, this is a good question.
Obviously, there's a lot of preparation going on in the back for a lot of things that you might not notice, Ruffians, but- You're not supposed to.
You're not supposed to, that's okay.
But, by far, FUWAMOCO Morning is the most demanding!
Yeah.
Surprised?
You may think it's just 30 minutes, but it actually takes much, much more time than that to prepare!
Yeah.
You know, we wake up three hours before every FUWAMOCO Morning to continue preparing everything.
And then we separate the tasks amongst ourselves too, you know.
It takes a lot of work and preparation to be able to meet you early like this almost every other day of the week.
But I think it's worth it to make your day a little brighter.
You know, especially before you have all those rough parts each day.
Yeah, so it means a lot when
We hear that FUWAMOCO means a lot to you too.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ah, yeah, FUWAMOCO Morning.
But also FUWAMOCO means a lot to you too.
Yeah.
But otherwise, we maybe like to have some more prep-heavy streams that involve more homework that we'd like to do in the future.
But, again, it takes a lot of work so it's hard to balance with everything else we have going on too.
What?
Balance.
It's tricky, you know?
But we'll continue working hard!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for all your submissions today too!
We're always looking forward to all your updates.
For more questions, questions, questions, questions.
For more vlogs.
Thank you.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a show that we make all together, Ruffians, so don't forget that, okay?
BAU BAU!
Why don't we take a peek at our next stream?
Our next stream is, if you know today, the day of the week, it is time for Resident Evil 4 Wednesday!
We're back to Resident Evil 4.
Yeah, we're playing the remake.
We just made it back to the village and are going to head inside the church.
You know, the church where all the grandmas and grandpas headed in, so they're so, so hurried.
I don't know why.
Then we're gonna hurt us really badly and then it's like, no!
It's great.
Don't question.
But hopefully things don't get too much scarier.
And also hopefully Moco-chan gets better at shooting.
But also, make sure that you're logged in and are all enough Ruffians to watch, okay?
It can be a little scary at times, so... But if you can't watch, what else do we have?
Well...
That's all.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians.
That brings our 31st FUWAMOCO Morning to an end.
Thank you so much for joining us today this morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Baby Tortilla!
BAU BAU BAU!
Mike L!
BAU BAU!
Lily.
Kosuzu.
BAU BAU!
Zende.
Bobman.
BAU BAU!
Udol.
Yahiro.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!